Andrew McCabe was supposed to be retired
right now he'd served in the FBI for
more than two decades and rose to be the
bureau's deputy director but on Friday
night at around 10:00 p.m. Eastern he
was stripped of his federal pension just
48 hours before it was set to kick in
fired by Attorney General Jeff Sessions
for quote lack of candor under oath on
multiple occasions
president Trump along critic of McCabe
called the termination a great day for
democracy mccabe maintains he was sacked
to undermine the credibility of the
special counsels investigation he's
turned over memos of his conversations
with the president to robert Muller's
team there's of course a firestorm of
reaction pouring in when the president
said there was a great day for democracy
yesterday I think it was a horrible day
for democracy to have firings like this
happening at the top from the president
and the Attorney General does not speak
well for what's going on you know his
firing may be justified there's no way
for us to know at this point but even
though it may have been justified it can
also be tainted
it was clearly rushed and I think there
are questions about that and whether the
administration was putting pressure on
the on the Justice Department to take
this action it appears to have been
compressed in order to take vengeance on
this guy Mandy McCabe has undercut his
credibility all by himself he didn't
need any help doing that former CIA
director John Brennan didn't hold back
his disdain for mr. Trump on Twitter
quote when the full extent of your
venality moral turpitude and political
corruption becomes known you will take
your rightful place as a disgraced
demagogue and the dustbin of history you
may scapegoat Andy McCabe but you will
not destroy America America will triumph
over you okay a little over the top
therefore mr. Brennan what I found
interesting Kimberly is in that montage
movie played yes Adam Schiff pretty
partisan Democrat he said could be a
possibility that this firing of McCabe
was completely justified what do you
think about the fire that tells me
everything you're gonna need to know he
wouldn't be going out on a limb and
saying something like that that might
displease his a part of
and you know bass that thinks that
President Trump is just you know running
amuck here by saying that tells me that
he has knowledge and information to
suggest that in fact it was justified
I think they wouldn't go out of their
way to do it when they did and how they
did it if they didn't have good reason
and full cause and hadn't investigated
it thoroughly and in fact the people
making the recommendation the people
that work with him at the FBI
so that really I think is quite
dispositive you know of the issue I mean
you brought a nice a humanitarian point
to it last week and you said well it's
two days before the guys you know
retirement was going to be AB so you
look at that aspect of it but
nevertheless if the facts are there and
persuasive and compelling then they have
to follow through with it one people are
saying that if it was just a regular guy
in the FBI who you know out in the field
and he did what McCabe did he'd be
treated the exact same way do you
understand that argument I don't think
that's true but I understand the
argument I think what's true is that you
know FBI agents are not rich people and
they really rely on pensions and so
typically there's a lot of leeway given
especially respect the idea always got
two days to go we'll let it happen but I
think what happened here is we don't
know and so what you're seeing Adams
shifts say is it could be that Adam
Schiff is just protecting himself from
possible blowback if you get a report
from the Inspector General in the Office
of Professional Responsibility that
indicates that McCabe either lied or was
not forthcoming with them then you would
say okay so there was justification for
it what we do know is that mccabe has
said that's not true that he either was
in chaos and was misunderstood or when
it but he says he did not lie or mislead
them so that's all we have on the table
at the moment Jesse but I will say this
given the politics surrounding
everything going on from the Comey
firing to the House Intelligence
Committee last week saying oh yeah
Russia they did in favor Donald Trump
you know it just looks like when you
look at this you can't ignore the
politics and the politics are stinking
you know obviously a lot of politics in
Washington that's to be expected Dana
do you think it was a little harsh or do
you think you know
the internal investigators think he did
a bad thing he should suffer the
consequences I would like to see the
full report before making a
determination because without that we're
just basically going on gut instinct to
what we hear or what might have been
leaked or not so until we have that but
I would say that politics are played
except for that there if the president
the president hadn't tweeted about this
on Saturday morning and rubbing McCabe's
face in it then the storyline would have
been the whole weekend is that the
Office of Professional Responsibility
recommended this firing and so that I
think would have been a nice place to
just leave it right there and let
everybody talk about the Office of
Professional Responsibility that didn't
happen that didn't happen it usually
doesn't when the president tweets Greg
what are your thoughts
all right my first thoughts Dana hair
looks great we lose him not to notice
pay attention to what she was saying I
uh I have both welcome let's the weird
thing here is Brennan's manifesto of a
tweet which was almost like written as
part of a West Wing script left over and
then but then what happens after he says
all this of magical you know a manicured
stuff Samantha Power's retweets and
writes don't like don't mess what you
don't want to get this guy angry it's
like high school it's like being in the
high school cafeteria and the
cheerleader runs over this let me hold
your jackets because you're gonna get in
a fight I mean maybe that's that
submission that Hillary keeps talking
about but um but his his anger it
reflects the deep animosity that
validates Trump's assumptions and it's
assertions about people in power who
want him gone that's the hood ornament
that tweet is the hood ornament of all
of these people who sincerely believe
that there is a bad man in the White
House and they got to get him out and it
end and it's it's the if you notice it's
the circle of media and the circle of
the Trump critics and they match
perfectly so they're a self-perpetuating
engine of panic so the media says oh my
god he's evil is evil and then you have
this dude and yab Comey and you got the
other guy and this guy who are in the
government saying the same thing these
are the same people the media and
and these these I guess you would call
them Washington insiders or establish
whatever the reactions are 99.9%
identical so that's where you get the
hysteria in the panic because they've
constantly it's there's no yin and yang
its yen and yen possibility that Donald
Trump is in the middle of the yin and
yang and that they're reacting to
something very real I would say that if
B if there was some kind of variability
in the reaction but when it's this
uniform and hysterical it makes me think
that it is almost emotionally driven and
also uniform was the reaction to this
and everybody says the next step
Muller is gone and let's hear some of
that I don't know what the designs are
on Muller but it seems to be building
toward that and I just hope it doesn't
go there because it can't I we can't in
Congress accept that he tried to do that
that would be the beginning of the end
of his presidency because we're rule of
law nation I would hope that it would
prompt all Democrats and Republicans in
the House to pass an independent council
law and reinstate Bob Muller this would
undoubtedly result in a constitutional
crisis and I think Democrats Republicans
need to speak out about this right now
so Kimberly do you believe there is
momentum building for firing Miller or
as Greg said is this just the self
perpetuation with the media and the
Democrats where they almost want this to
happen and they're pushing it it's a
little bit of the self perpetuation
merry-go-round the one that you want to
get our five before you throw up but
yeah I don't think that he's going to
make a move like that I think it would
be ill-advised at this point to do
something like that given that this has
already gone so far down the road
they're sort of on the five-inch line
let them complete the investigation I
don't see any upside for the president
in removing him at this juncture only
downside will be tremendous amount of
fallout and criticism we saw that when
that happened there with Comey okay and
I just don't think this should follow in
the footsteps you've got McCabe on do
the investigation complete it come to
the conclusion see it through to you
know all the way through fruition and
then see what we had Jesse this isn't
the first time that the president may
have thought about firing ball remember
last June there January that oh he's
being thinking about it and then people
say oh no no he would never do it then
it was confirmed that in fact he was
thinking of doing just that and now
again what we've seen this weekend boy I
thought he just was manic in the tweets
the attacks on the intelligence
community FBI Isis I mean wand it was a
deflection Trump was tweeting so you
didn't notice that he was colluding with
Putin to win the election and in Russia
that was that he was helping he was
helping Putin win here I want to give
you that today I wanted to give you a
new conspiracy president for life
that's your new conspiracy okay the best
part of this and I know you hate the
word for two signaling XT words I don't
have all the people offering to pay the
pension for mchao to pay yeah but the
next thing is like they care so much
about a questionable bureaucrats pension
than actual real suffering oh that's a
good point
all right it's just a little bit of
advice you know I was spokesperson for
Karl Rove during the special counsel and
it's very difficult to figure out the
legal strategy and the communication
strategy but they really must work in
tandem it's a terrible idea for the
lawyers to be out front and not in
communication or coordination with the
PR people because the other thing that
happened this weekend or this past week
is you had reports that questions from
the Moller team had gone to Trump's
lawyers but these are the types of
things we won't want to ask him if we
were to have an interview with him so
they're negotiating that so now the
president knows what that is
there's a subpoena to the Trump
Organization there's McCabe's firing
there's the Dowd comments the his
lawyers comments about Mullard that this
should all end and he says yes I'm
speaking on behalf of the president and
now relays like oh actually no I'm
speaking of my own capacity I don't
believe any of that I actually think
that they're one of their major problems
is they have to get their PR people wind
up and in sync with their legal people
or they're going to continue to have new
cycles like that yep it was just amazing
after all this data that Hillary was the
one that colluded with the Russians